hello fellow travelers we launched
journey to the micro cosmos knowing that
there would be you know some people who
would be interested in the magnificence
of this world that exists beyond our
view and that some portion of those
people would like to enjoy that world
with a more laid-back vibe than your
average YouTube video that feels like a
fraction of a fraction of an audience so
we were not expecting this level of
response your comments your thoughts
your support it's been really special
for us for James and his cultures and
Europe for me and Matt here in Missoula
Montana and for DES boki over on the
East Coast writing and fact-checking
this process it's been really something
special starting out we planned to make
a total of 30 episodes of journey to the
micro cosmos
we're now on our way to Episode fifteen
and no one on the team thinks that were
halfway done with this anymore we want
to keep going we want more original
music from Andrew Huang we want better
equipment so we can see more and deeper
at higher resolutions and frame rates we
want more time and resources to get to
the bottom of the mysteries were most
curious about we also want to provide
the folks that love what we do with a
little extra and to get you involved so
as you might have expected would
eventually happen and as many of you
have been asking for which is wonderful
we have a patreon now our patreon only
has one level it's $8 a month and it
gets everyone the same things first you
will be thanked in the credits of all
videos while you're a patron second once
a month we'll be sending you an
hour-long unmerited video that will show
off Andrew Wong's full-length tracks
deeper cuts of our footage and third a
weekly wallpaper an image as
high-resolution as we can get of some of
our favorite microbes for you to use on
your computer phone or just print out
and put on your actual wall we know that
ultimately what people want out of a
patreon is to support the channel not to
make a bunch of extra work for us and
that's what we want to and we want to
thank you
I've been making YouTube videos for a
long time and I've never had a channel
gather such a die-hard fan base so fast
this has been really wonderful thank you
for coming on this journey with us as we
explore the unseen world that surrounds
us
you